we're asked which of these strategies
would eliminate a variable in the system
of equations choose all answers that
apply so this first one says add the
equation so pause this video would
adding the equations eliminate a
variable in the system alright now let's
do it together so if we add these
equations we have on the left hand side
we have 5x plus 5x which is going to be
10x and then you have negative 3y plus
4y which is just a positive 1y or just
plus y is equal to negative 3 plus 6
which is just going to be equal to
positive 3 we haven't eliminated any
variables so choice a I could rule out
that did not eliminate a variable let me
cross it out and not check it subtract
the bottom equation from the top well
when we subtract the bottom from the top
5x minus 5x that's going to be 0 X's so
I won't even write it down and we've
already seen we've eliminated an X so
I'm already feeling good about choice B
but then we can see negative 3y minus 4y
is negative 7y negative 3 minus 6 is
going to be negative 9 and so choice B
does successfully eliminate the X's so I
will select that choice C multiply the
top equation by 2 then add the equations
pause the video does that eliminate a
variable well we're gonna multiply the
top equation by 2 so it's going to
become 10x minus 6y is equal to negative
6 and you could already see if you then
add the equations 10x plus 5x you're
gonna have 15 X that's not gonna get
eliminated negative 6y plus 4y is
negative 2y that's not going to be
eliminated so we can rule that out as
well let's do another example 1 they're
asking us the same question which of
these strategies would eliminate a
variable in the system of equations the
first choice says multiply the bottom
equation by 2 then add the equations
pause this video does that work alright
so if we multiply the bottom equation by
2 we are going to get if we must
by - we're gonna get 2x - 2 - 4 why I
should say 2x I'm just multiplying
everything by 2 - 4 y is equal to 10 and
then if we were to add the equations 4x
plus 2x is 6x so that doesn't get
eliminated positive 4y + negative 4y is
equal to 0 wise so the Y's actually do
get eliminated when you add 4y -
negative 4y so I like choice a and I'm
gonna delete this so I have space to
work on the other choices so I like this
one
what about choice B pause the video does
that work multiply the bottom equation
by 4 then subtract the bottom equation
from the top equation alright let's
multiply the bottom equation by 4 what
do we get we're going to get 4x minus 8y
is equal to 20 yet we multiplied it by 4
and then subtract the bottom equation
from the top so we would subtract 4x
from 4 X well that's looking good that
would eliminate the x's so i'm feeling
good about choice B and then we could
see if we subtract negative 8y from 4y
while subtracting a negative the same
thing as adding a positive so that would
actually give us 212 Y if we're
subtracting negative 8y from 4y and then
if we subtract 20 from negative 2 we get
2 negative 22 but we see that 4x minus
4x is going to eliminate our x's so that
does definitely eliminate a variable so
I like choice B now what about choice C
multiply the top equation by 1/2 then
add the equations let's try that out
pause the video all right let's just
multiply times 1/2 so the left-hand side
times 1/2 we distribute the 1/2 is one
way to think about it 4x times 1/2 is
going to be 2x plus 4y times 1/2 is 2 y
is equal to negative 2 times 1/2 is
equal to negative 1 now and then they
say add the equations so 2x plus X is
going to be 3x so that's not going to
eliminate the x's 2y plus negative 2y
well that's going to be No
so that actually will eliminate the Y's
so I like this choice as well so
actually all three of these strategies
would eliminate a variable in the system
of equations this is useful to see
because you can see there's multiple
ways to approach a solving a system like
this through elimination let's do
another example which of these
strategies would eliminate a variable in
the system of equations same question
again so the first one they suggest is
subtract the bottom equation from the
top equation pause this video does that
work well if we subtract the bottom from
the top so if you subtract a negative 2x
that's the same thing as adding 2x just
you're adding 2x - 3 X that's 5 X the
X's don't get eliminated subtracting 4y
from negative 3y is just gonna get us to
negative 7y the y's don't get eliminated
so I would rule this one out nothing's
getting eliminated there multiply the
top equation by 3 multiply the bottom
equation by 2 then add the equations
pause the video does that work alright
so if I multiply the top equation by 3
I'm going to get 9x minus 9y is equal to
21 and then I find multiply the bottom
by 2 so this is times 2 I'm going to get
2 times negative 2 is negative 4x plus
8y is equal to 14 and then they say add
the equations well if I add 9x -
negative 4x that doesn't eliminate the
X's that gets me to a positive 5x and if
I add negative 9 wide a positive 8y that
also doesn't eliminate the Y's I guess
me - a negative Y so choice B I can also
rule out once again deleting all of this
I have space to try to figure out choice
C multiply the top equation by 2
multiply the bottom equation by 3 then
add the equation so they're telling us
to do it the other way around pause the
video does this does this work alright
so we multiply the top equation by 2 and
we're going to multiply the bottom
equation by 3
so the top equation times 2 is going to
be 6x minus 6y is equal to is equal to
14 and then with this
McQuade when you multiply it by three
both sides that's the only way to ensure
that the equation is seeing the same
thing is if you do the same thing to
both sides that's really the heart of
algebra so negative 2 times 3 is
negative 6x and I already like where
this is going because when I add these
two they're going to get eliminated plus
4y times 3 is going to be plus 12 y is
going to be equal to 21 and then they
say add the equations well you
immediately see when you add the X terms
on the left-hand side they are going to
cancel out so I like choice
C